forcés pour nos concitoyens contaminés
la vaccination des professionnels au
contact de personnes vulnérables
nul ne peut dire que cela sera suffisant
mais je vais vous recommander de donner
ses chances à ce dispositif en vous
proposant toutefois de le rendre plus
simple plus claire plus efficace plus
respectueux des libertés
je vais donc vous proposer de prendre
position sur ces questions essentielles
la première est celle du cadre de
l'action des pouvoirs publics
sommes nous toujours dans la gestion de
la sortie de l'urgence sanitaire ou
sommes-nous revenus dans l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
il est clair qu un régime de pouvoir
exceptionnelle justifiée par une flambée
des contaminations par un variant de
vous ne cessez de rappeler monsieur le
ministre que sa charge virale est mille
fois plus élevé que le virus initial ne
peut se justifier à l'évidence que par
le retour à l'état d'urgence
la privation de droits fondamentaux pour
toutes les personnes qui ne peuvent
produire un pass sanitaire l'obligation
vaccinale imposé à des catégories très
large de professionnels la mise à
l'isolément des porteurs du virus
constituent des mesures tellement
exorbitante du droit commun qu'elles ne
sont concevables qu à titre temporaire
dans le cadre d'une urgence sanitaire
reconnu et sous un contrôle
parlementaire et juridictionnelles
accrue
[Musique]